[Música]
es la hora de hablar de las noticias de
salud y para eso me acompaña Mari Romero
salamar Buen día para usted Buenos días
Ángela vamos a volver a hablar de un
tema recurrente y es el de la gripe
hablar la OMS se pronunció sobre el
riesgo estoy con la lengua enredada que
esto puede suponer para nosotros los
humanos si hace meses que el virus se
extiende entre los pájaros por eso lo
venimos repitiendo aquí en este espacio
de salud ahora saltado algunos mamíferos
y sobre eso se pronunció precisamente
como decías la Organización Mundial de
la Salud escuchémoslo de
monitor El Salto reciente del virus a
los mamíferos requiere monitoreo cercano
por ahora la OMS valora el riesgo para
los humanos como bajo
desde que h5n1 emergió en 1996 solo
hemos visto contagios raros y no
sostenidos en los humanos pero no
podemos asumir que esto seguirá así y
debemos estar preparados para cualquier
cambio
como decían en la Organización Mundial
de la Salud los casos que salte el virus
a humanos son raros las cifras de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud desde
2003 Es que hay 868 casos de los cuales
en 20 años de los cuales han fallecido
más de la mitad es una mortalidad
bastante alta Aunque este salto humanos
sea poco probable porque el virus está
poco adaptado a los animales mamíferos
Aunque Por eso hay hasta cierta alarma
de que ha saltado de los aves a los
mamíferos y eso podría hacer que se
estuviera acercando o que aumentaran las
probabilidades de que se adapte el virus
mejor para tener un contagio sostenido
en los humanos como decíamos hasta ahora
es difícil que haya cadenas de
transmisión entre personas bueno igual
no la preocupación usted ha visto estos
sacrificios que hacen de animales cada
vez que se detectan algunos casos ahora
acercándolo a nuestro continente cuál es
la situación en América Sí el primer
caso en la región se detectó en 2014
pero es cierto que en los últimos meses
a raíz también de que se contagien no
solo aves de corral sino también aves
salvajes ha llegado al continente
americano de nuevo nuevas oleadas y se
ha extendido más ampliamente se
registran actualmente brotes de naves en
diez países de la región como Ven aquí
están marcados en un color digamos verde
y en cambio Estados Unidos y Ecuador
toca nombrarlo especialmente porque se
han detectado casos en humanos solo uno
en Estados Unidos solo uno en Ecuador el
de Ecuador de hecho ha sido
recientemente en 2023 en enero de 2023
en una niña que afortunadamente pues ya
se está recuperando qué podemos hacer
frente a esto también es una pregunta no
que nos debemos hacer por supuesto
primero vigilar los entornos en los que
hay un contacto estrecho entre humanos y
aves que las personas que están en este
contrato por ejemplo que trabajan en
granjas de aves tomen precauciones
sanitarias no tocar aves muertas bajo
ningún concepto y pues prepararse
también a nivel estructural no hay
vacunas hay antivirales podemos hacerle
frente a esto si desde ya pues nos
preparamos en caso de que haya un
posible salto a humanos qué indignación
en México mar vamos a hablar de la
conclusión de un brote de meningitis del
cual no se conocía el origen sí sonó
meses de investigación que dieron un
paso adelante el martes y que nos hablan
de una historia de verdadero terror
ahora vamos a explicarlo se detuvo a
tres presuntos responsables para
concluir que realmente el origen de la
enfermedad fue una irresponsabilidad
humana el brote recordemos deja ya 35
víctimas mortales 79 personas
contagiadas en el estado de Durango
especialmente en la capital también
Durango La mayoría eran mujeres jóvenes
que habían dado a luz recientemente y
esto está relacionado porque se cree que
este brote está relacionado con la
anestesia que se usó para por ejemplo
los procesos de cesárea también se
detuvo a la anestesiólogo presunto
responsable principal y a personas que
sean responsables digamos de la comisión
para la protección contra los riesgos
sanitarios hay siete sospechosos más que
están prófugos todavía qué vergüenzamar
qué vergüenza ahora cómo fue la cadena
de eventos que terminó En estos casos de
meningitis pues esclarecer lo ha tomado
un tiempo la meningitis es un nombre
genérico para la inflamación de los
tejidos del cerebro de la médula espinal
y que normalmente de hecho lo producen
bacterias en este caso lo que lo produjo
fue un hongo hay cuatro hospitales
privados de Durango que están
relacionados con este brote uno de ellos
operaba sin licencia y se usó la
bupivacaína que es una anestesia Como
decíamos por ejemplo aplicada durante
las cesáreas resulta que no estaba en
buen estado debido a malos procesos de
conservación y que a una de estas
personas la había cambiado de hospital
en hospital había ingresado digamos sin
permiso de Centro sanitario a centro
sanitario se había desarrollado un hongo
el fusario solani y entonces eso fue lo
que provocó la inflamación no esta
infección el primer contagio fue en
octubre se pensaron que eran casos
aislados inicialmente hasta que se vio
que no que se estaba extendiendo por
suerte al menos ahora se ha atajado se
ha encontrado la causa y se están
empezando Pues a buscar esta
responsabilidades pues mire aquí casi
todos los días se elogian los avances
científicos y hoy pues rechazar
completamente estos malos procesos por
supuesto tener muy en claro que damos
nuestra vida no los médicos y que tienen
que tener estos procesos responsables ni
más faltaba gracias a usted gracias
Ángela